esses sintomas podem indicar que a
doença está evoluindo para uma forma
mais grave como a dengue hemorrágica ou
a síndrome do Choque da Dengue são
situações que podem ser realmente
perigosas primeiro sangramentos anormais
isso pode aparecer de várias formas pode
ser um sangramento nasal sem motivo
aparente um aumento no fluxo menstrual
nas mulheres sangramento nas gengivas ou
até mesmo pequenas manchas de sangue na
pele segundo se você perceber uma queda
na pressão arterial mesmo que seja leve
isso pode ser um sinal precoce de um
choque por isso atenção monitorar a
pressão arterial é uma medida muito
importante preventiva para queem está
enfrentando a dengue uma pressão
arterial muito baixa que requer atenção
médica é inferior a 90 por 60 9x 6
terceiro uma dor abdominal intensa mais
do que um desconforto Essa dor pode ser
um sinal de que há problemas mais sérios
acontecendo incluindo possíveis lesões
no fígado em